we start with the pandemic and new
guidelines from the centers for disease
control
as more americans get vaccinated what we
can do and
how we do it is changing so here are the
new recommendations they allow people
who are fully vaccinated
to gather with others who have also
received the medicine they can be in
small groups
they don't have to wear masks however
the cdc is asking vaccinated people to
keep wearing masks and practice social
distancing in public
it also advises us all to avoid medium
and large
large in-person gatherings still over 90
of the population is not yet vaccinated
and that is our responsibility
to make sure in the context of 60 000
new cases a day
that we protect those who remain
unvaccinated and remain
vulnerable meanwhile new money for a
national vaccination program is included
in president biden's american rescue
plan
that plan is enormous it passed the
senate over the weekend
the measure needs a final vote in the
house before heading to the president's
desk